i do i've had some terrible [ __ ]
clients when i did a lot of commercials
because they would bring in like a
business executive
right to come in and critique and they
don't [ __ ] know anything
right and they would i remember one time
there was a guy and i did this
whole take i thought i killed it and he
was like
yeah something's like off with it this
wasn't the director this was just the
guy who was paying for it to be made
and he was like yeah could you just try
something different i did the exact same
thing again
no different and he was like that was
perfect and i was like i was like i
[ __ ] knew it
because like i know okay i in my head
i'm like i know i can get away with
doing the same thing
one more time but like maybe not a
second time so i was like i'll just try
once see if he notices he had no idea
yeah at that point onwards anytime he
said anything i would just look at the
voice director
over there i would look at him i'm like
should i listen to this
like he was the engineer and the
director of the thing right yeah
he so he normally does the deliver the
way i the way it was set up for me was
he normally directed me and the client
would just stand there and go like
yes yes like because i was always doing
business stuff
right it was like it's like perseverance
inspiration
[ __ ] like that you did like a gillette
commercial right or it wasn't
like a like a shaving cream commercial
whatever it was something
else ages ago i was doing like
boats for like a year you did both i did
like a
there was some oh i can't i don't know
what the corporation is and i also don't
know if i should say i don't know if i'm
allowed i don't know what i signed i
go once a week i would go in
for three hours and i would talk about
boats wait how old were you
this was like last year oh really every
week i went in and talked about it in
london right yes
in london yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i got
paid like [ __ ] like how much was it they
were paying me
250 pounds an hour oh wow uh which is
like 300 something bucks
yeah and just talk about boats which is
probably like a lot better than what
voice actors get paid to voice an anime
yeah
definitely uh yeah anime rates aren't
that great i mean i don't i don't know
if
you know i'm gonna i'll just say like i
mean i definitely didn't get paid
i've heard things and uh i you know you
get paid on
funimation from what i've been told i
don't know if this is true i don't know
i'm allowed to say this but it's not
it's not great it's not
i feel less than what i was getting yeah
i mean it's like i think it's always
just been known that
the voice acting industry in anime
specifically just like
paid the least yeah you get paid at
least out of any commercial which is why
you see a lot of dub voice actors going
on to do gaming now yeah
industries the the way it goes is like
it's like uh
normally commercials pay the most
because commercials you get paid
normally a premium and then you also get
what's called a buyout fee
so if your ad is going to be played over
x amount of places with radios tv
that gets calculated in the cost yeah
and you could get like one commercial
that takes you 20 minutes which
it often did because commercials are 30
seconds long
mostly and i would never be there for
more than 30 minutes but
they would maybe pay you like 15 grand
for the biopsy
so your session fee was like 250 pounds
yeah but then you might get 15 grand or
10.
depending on where they play it and how
much because i know the guy who did
mcdonald's ads in the uk that was his
whole career yeah he's doing mcdonald's
really yeah because you got he got paid
so far oh yeah
it is mcdonald's six figures every
commercial
because you know that's luckily how the
industry was that you got paid if your
voice was being
imagine getting paid six figures by
going but
i wish right that's the thing like
imagine how much
how much money mcdonald's made off of
that right
because normally how it is with
commercials is that if you're
normally with voices if a corporation
gets one voice actor it's normally
always that one voice act who does
everything so
in the industry where when i was in
london it was mainly commercial stuff so
it came up a lot and it was always like
people were competing
to get that one commercial gig that kept
coming
yeah and so i got this boat gig i didn't
think of anything of it
um because i didn't audition they like
requested me so i went in i did a read
for it and i was talking about um
i had to explain a ton of different
things about large ships
for a corporation thing okay and i had
to go in every week and do something
ballasting that was what i did like
[ __ ] four weeks of
thing called ballasting right ballasting
is a thing and i know this because i did
four scripts
sell us a bit what is ballasting sir he
was like it was like
it was like god i wish i remembered the
words and i remember every time i would
go in to deliver it because my accent is
is english right but it's not uh
received pronunciation which is the styp
typical of the accent which is i say
grass but it's grass
so every time i would do anything he's
like you didn't you didn't say the the
received pronunciation
do it again i'm like oh yes of course
ballasting you know is the you know like
that it was basically where water
goes in the ships and they dunk it dump
it out later on
okay but there was like so many
scientific words and i was like
it was the the sodium hydrosis oxide
oxygenation thing and i was like all
right